gardez-vous de croiser les bras en
l'attitude stérile du spectateur car la
vie n'est pas ce spectacle quelques
phrases de césaire en écho aux
souffrances du quotidien un soleil de
plomb pèse chaque jour sur le collège
julien nicolas né salle de classe sans
store sans clim pour deux tiers d'entre
elles et au ventilateur défectueux
aujourd'hui toute la communauté scolaire
crie au secours
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui dans des
salles avec une chaleur insoutenable qui
avoisine et 34° à certains moments donc
ce qui a provoqué le malaise de certains
enseignants
le malaise de certains élèves ça fait
peur ça ça fait très peur aujourd'hui
vous ne reprenez pas cours tant que vous
n'avez pas d'engagement je pense que
c'est normal
il en va de notre intégrité physique de
l'intégrité physique des élèves
l'atmosphère est d'autant plus étouffant
depuis la construction du commissariat
voisin qui prive le collège des alizés à
julien nicolas les travaux de
climatisation promis par la ctm avant
les vacances n'ont pas eu lieu
ils sont pourtant urgent aux dires mêmes
des parents
j'ai deux enfants ici au collège les
élèves en 4e
j'en ai qui porte des verres il a
souvent des migraines locle a mal au
ventre parce que sur ce décès tout ça
peut voir ça leur enlève des chances
pour leur année scolaire des choses
réussite si l'enfant pendant la journée
et dans un fond ils n'arrivent pas à se
concentrer
donc il n'y a appris de toute la journée
mercredi prochain la communauté scolaire
recevra la conseillère exécutive en
charge de l'éducation
actuellement en déplacement notre
problème seront évoqués comme l'absence
totale de vestiaires pour les filles au
gymnase des clients à reconstruire
depuis un an déjà